[Music]
[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about everything we know about the
season 8 premiere
supportive trailers teasers and even a
few actual leaked shots from episode 1
that was leaked by carries van hauden an
actress who plays melisandre
a week ago the stars of game of thrones
descended on radio city music hall in
new york city to watch the season a
premiere
reporters and critics from several
outlets were there as well
and have already given their thoughts on
the episode according to indy wire the
disembodied voices of sophie turner
sansa stark and maisie williams the arya
star could be heard before the show
started
warning the audience members about the
spoilers no photos no videos no posting
spoilers on social media
however there are few people who filmed
some moments from season 8 premiere
and among them is kirsten hauren who
filmed 15 seconds of the interest new
look
and posted it on her instagram story
revealing that the final season of game
of thrones has a shiny new intro
first take a look at how the wall has
changed with that massive hole at
eastwatch
this is obviously a reference to the
scene at the end of season 7 when the
night king destroyed portion of the wall
by
using the undead dragon viserion the ice
floor that spreads out from the wall
representing the night king and his army
who bring the storm in winter goes to
lost heart
the state of house summer as we all know
if we see a location on the map
in the intro it means that we'll visit
in the episode what it means is that the
night king and his army of the dead will
attack last heart
just as johnstone stated they would in
the season 7 premiere if the wolf falls
with this attack the night king starts
his conquest or westeros
last card will fall and endumber along
with it most likely
there's this one shot from the official
trailer in which we see ed barry and
tormund
and are most likely there at lost heart
but after the night king already
attacked the place
just as i explained in the trailer
breakdown barrican tormund then straight
to castle black
after the destruction of the east watch
and reunited the ted the acting lord
commander of the night's watch
gathered as many men as they could and
marched south i said that this must be
them arriving in a theater last heart
castle of house summer or car hold
castle of house car stark both of which
will probably be destroyed by the night
king
but since the season a premiere visits
last heart i am now quite certain that's
the place the night king will attack
first
and that's the place where we see these
three in the trailer on its aftermath
they basically arrive to see nothing
there are no dead
nor alive everyone who is defending it
is now a part of the army of the dead
this was not the only clip from the
opening that made it onto the internet
another fan filmed a short shot from the
intro ship to king's landing
this clip doesn't cover as much
territory as the first one but there's
still many things that are different
than usual
instead of just gliding of the red keep
the new opening credits take us inside
where we see dragon's skull that we have
seen in season 7.
the only thing we can get from this part
is that it's changed
before i get right into puzzling of the
first episode of the final season we
look based on everything we have these
are trailers and official spoilers
here are some other highlights posted by
people who attended the exclusive
premiere
they claim that there are plenty of
witty one-liners peppered throughout the
episode
somehow probably thanks to bran then he
learns with darion was raised by the
night king
who then used the dragon to break the
wall which actually puzzled out how and
many happens
thanks to the new teasers then he will
also have to deal with jon snight sniffy
sisters
and the north nurse and winterfell but
it will not stop her and john from
canoodling in public
the secret of jon's parentage will not
be a secret for very long
all the statements are very interesting
and much revealing to be honest
some other highlights include statements
like there's no filler in the premiere
the pace is near relentless episode 801
could be the funniest episode in the
history of thrones
a lot of characters appear in the
premiere but not everyone gets lines
and then this for readers of a betting
disposition varys has to be high on the
death list now
closely followed by miss sandy grey
warren pogic and whispered tyrion
pretty interesting stuff that pretty
much confirmed many main events
such as the truth behind joshua
parentage being revealed to him
and possibly twitter's as well in the
season 8 premiere
now that i brought you the new season 18
show and highlights shared by reporters
and critics
from several outlets who got to watch
the premiere early let's continue this
video with the opening scene
so after we see a new intro the episode
starts with the arrival of jon snow and
dany at winterfell
at the end of season 7 dany and john are
sailing towards white harbor
the main seaport of the north with the
unsullied once they arrive over there
they'll meet the track in the king's
road
and then ride together to winterfell
most of this will probably take place of
screen
and will only see them approaching and
entering winterfell and the trailer
provided that shot
this right here is one of the opening
scenes of season 8 with jon and dany
passing through winter town and arriving
in winterfell
beside jon daniel armies of course
dragons survive as well
and sensa seems to be just as impressed
as zarya is
we have already known for quite some
time that jon and danny will arrive at
vanerfell in the very first episode of
the final season
in a callback to the series very first
episode of the first season
with danny and her camp standing in for
king robert and his
so then he arrives at winner fell with
john and their cruise john then
introduces her to his family and what
follows is a tense meeting between danny
and sansa
which he first found out from the first
official season 8 easter posted by
entertainment weekly
they posted an entire season 8 cover
story online which includes a detailed
description of the opening scene
there it says that sensei said not to be
thrilled that jon bended into his new
fancy targaryen girlfriend
at least not at first and we saw what
they meant by that when game of thrones
released a short clip of that very
meeting
sensa does say vannerfeld is your sir
grace the same line her father said to
king robert when he arrived at
winterfell
but by sansa's face expression we can
see that she doesn't like any of that
then he's not here in nor to conquer the
north but rather to save it
and that's something the northern lords
will see for themselves and recognize
her as true ally eventually
emilia clarke discusses how danny feels
when she arrives at the stark's home
i like to think that it's like me the
parents it's like i hope they like me
this dude's wicked it's a real good
thing we got going on
here's the final piece we're destined
for greatness and world domination is a
breath away
and so i need to be like can i braid
your hair sansa lil arya come over here
let's play some cricket so there's that
and then very very quickly it's like
wait is it just me or do they hate me
however this will not be danny's only
tense first meeting
as beside the lady of nfl she is also
going to meet john snow's best friend
samuel tarly
whose father and brother she burned
alive during this past season
many argues sam will not care about it
and truth be told he probably will not
mourn much about his father
but he might care about his brother
hopefully samuel understands that dany
did not have a choice
even after his family helped the
lannister destroy dany's most powerful
ally
or lena tyrell then he still gave them a
chance to bend the knee which they
refused
then he did not have a choice so yes
there will be some tension between dany
and sansa
as well as between dany and same until
they see for themselves who dana truly
is
and what her true intentions are beside
all the attention winterfell
will also host quite a huge amount of
reunions starting with jon snow and his
family and friends
john will renate sansa bran and sam and
his direwolf ghost early on in the
episode
and a bit later vitaria as well arya
will not be with sansa and bran in the
courtyard though winterfell when jon and
danny arrive to greet jon and dany
arya seems to be a winner town at the
moment of january's arrival
new footage provided this clip of john
and arya being in the godswood of
winterfell
arya and jon have not seen each other
since season 1 but they had very close
sibling relationship
and they just missed each other in
season 7. and now in season 8 they will
finally reunite
it's going to be heartbreaking speaking
of arya there will most likely be no
intense moments between her and danny
in fact i think that danny and arya will
get along very well
considering how both of them admire and
respect strong and powerful women
also since arya is passionate about
their gaming history negan dragon
riding's his survives has seen in season
2
if azania targaryen being her heroine we
can imagine she is predisposed to lie
can be fascinated by dany
and her dragon since season 8 which this
clip seems to be suggesting
everyone is in fear of such beats flying
above them but arya stark is happy to
finally see one
after greeting john's family then he
will likely receive shocking news about
her dragon vitarion
in this shot we have danny at the
courtyard of winterfell which is from
the season a premiere
and we know it's her meeting all the
starks since dany is in the ground level
of winterfell courtyard and looking down
and she is a little upset
she is likely listening to brandon's
wheelchair who is telling her about the
wall
the night king and viserion bram
basically shares the news that the night
king used the dragon to bring the ball
down
and it will not be long until they're
here as we all know dany knew she lost
the dragon
but she did not know the night king
reanimated him and will basically fight
dany in the future
so this is definitely coming as a huge
shock to the dragon queen
what follows next is an urgent meeting
at minerval with majority of the
northern lords and the north's allies to
the great hall
in order to discuss their strategy and
defenses against the night king
almost all the main characters will be
there which we've got to see from the
first season 8 photos
we got to see davos sansa dani and
brienne but make no mistake almost all
main characters of the series will be
there as well
most likely including jaime davos
listens carefully as he sits with a
winter ready and solid soldier behind
him
judging by the look of davos he might
even be looking at lady melisandre
returning to winterfell
which is only a matter of time until she
does that's just a possibility
although davos could also be looking at
basically anyone brienne's look also
seems intense
and when you look deeper into it it also
seems as if she's afraid of the person
she loves
could she be looking at jaime lannister
has he already arrived at winterfell
the last time we saw jaime he finally
left cersei and he was wearing this same
armor on his way out of winterfell
now he also has a beard and a northern
armored shoulder pads
he either put those for disguise or
combat or it could even possibly mean
that by this time he has already pledged
to house stark
and those shoulder pads that look
exactly like robs are given to him by
the starks
ok guys this will be about the first
half of all the things we know about the
season 8 premiere based on teasers
trailers and official spoilers
while the other half is currently
processed and will be published as soon
as possible
so make sure to stay tuned for that and
as always i hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our channel and i hope to
see you in the next one
peace